poi alla panna
di dare ha barato qui
oggi siamo alla vita
berlino per liberare così faremo la pop
hit chart
cibo pop hit versus cibo reale
quindi come sempre spolli chat e costoso
come funziona in una di queste cross c'è
un po kate a forma di cibo è un'altra
c'è il cibo reale ci seguite da tanto
sapete che vitale è un mangione ma anche
merlino serio fra il giudice anzi col
suonato il suo fiuto ci aiuterà a capire
dov'è il cibo vince chi prende più cibo
pronti
forse non mi seguite su integra un
grandate a seguirmi e iniziamo con il
primo
celje per primo vitale quale gloss
scegli se vuoi farti aiutare da me
rimane nuvola scelgo questa o questa
secondo me berlino ha indicato bene puoi
decidere se tenerlo se scambiarla no no
la tengo parlino dice questo 2
abbiamo le banane e contro
punto per me può dominare una banana
anche se gioco con berlino vuole portare
invece non mangia niente
è vitale mi hai consigliato per a tre
soli
[Risate]
secondo
attenzione perché il cibo che troveremo
non è tutto buono
che prevede il cibo cattivo lo devi
mangiare per forza nonno e ti toglie un
punto dobbiamo stare attenti come
scegliere questa volta li ha nascosti
vitale quindi non so dove il 5 dopo che
il giudice ha abbandonato il suo posto
quindi non mi posso far aiutare da
merlino a distanza si cover quali
sarayuth bobbit lo tengo lo scambio lo
scambio poche quello che non mi convince
vediamo poi cambiarlo non so cosa dovrei
fare di sicura e l'età di risposta
definitiva e va bene dentro festa ok 33
si
no ma quello sarebbe un idoneo
perché noi abbiamo l'albero dei limoni
ma è piccolino quindi fa dei limoni
piccolissimi limoni ho fatto un punto e
vitale ora devo leggere
no io ho fatto un punto perché ha preso
il cibo no perché il cibo non è quello
buono
ma mai detto l'inizio di grecia il cibo
c'è un punto
americani nel cibo non buono quindi sei
almeno le istruzioni non erano chiare
l'italia dovrà mangiare il livore avete
commette da capi e limone io nel
frattempo gioco con il mio conflitto
limone mi raccomando del montello
davvero non partita è
dai mangiano una fettina
problema mangio by
[Musica]
mi fanno male i denti non molto dolce in
precedenza
e adesso un po a gillet come credo tutti
mangiando anch'io che poi dalla stessa
esistenza
terzo occhio visone sceglieranno rudd
ottieni 1 scampi lo scambio
peggio per te che non hai chiesto
l'aiuto del giudice giudice aiutami e
questo quello rantire
[Musica]
quanto è rivolto mole vitone è kate
veri contro la sentiva già quelli un
pizzo di blasi se li vorresti questo
aspetto se facciamo un accordo allora
tour nei due giorni o due
ragazzi così ne abbiamo un artista le
scelte io dividiamo un punto così romina
mi dispiace per te 3 a meno uno ma non
si crede che concede così facilmente
punto non ci credo
ma io quindi sarà meno dura vedere come
parole giusto guardate a un po di
cioccolato poi alla panna
sopra un cupcakes buonissimo
[Musica]
[Risate]
territori gli imbroglioni
vita e ho barato
[Musica]
questi giorni e
tutto
quanto ma ho detto che a me scegliere se
tenerlo o
cambiarlo
secondo me vitale si è messo il cibo qua
quindi lo scambia
secondo me qualcosa di buono rete
[Musica]
e questa volta però fatto a prenderlo un
punto e
gigante guardate il pop hit che
l'avvocato sono belli
finalmente posso mangiare o la carta ho
mangiato che arrivò
finalmente un punto per vitale quindi
vado a gerosa no
vabbè almeno questo pop hit bellissimo
forma di avvocato che carino come
il vino buono sia più buono di quello
sei contento che mi avete mangiato
qualcosa era un addio perché non tutto
anche prima la
scusa ti sei vendicato è permesso
marquinhos lo faccio
qui parole è tornato in b giudice doveva
donino che potrà aiutare vitale perché
[Musica]
questa volta deve decidere vitale se
tenerlo o
scambiarli
questo quello e non capisco questo
mi sa che lo scambio allora berlino
scambiarlo per
l'inail ha indicato chiaramente quello
quindi tendiamo a contrarsi io mi fido
di berlino vediamo che cosa fate
sommergibili quando aiuto sono
perfino
in giro
sento male quindi giusto
aspettiamo raccontare aspettarsi che un
gatto questo cane
così dopo il tocco resto bambini
uno di questi quasi dovevo sfidare della
tua scelta quella che ha fatto prima
quella di adesso non l'ho scaricato
presenti ormai l'ho scambiato quindi
ritengo questo ok
hai fatto male non fidarvi di berlino
perché il milan fiuto infallibile
malasanità davanti a dare del graziano
c'è il pop il jazz numero uscirà abitare
anche questa volta a roma di calciotto
merlino che è impossessato del
ghiacciolo che vuol dire che è ormai non
lo so devo mangiare
essere un piano di merlino fin
dall'inizio
perché merlino che se vitale prende il
cibo sono
giudici a berlino
lo prendo io a venire
passiamo ora a lungo
ultimo nodo di tocca a me decidere
speravo che berlino mi aiutate e invece
merlino venuto più rivolta solo regione
sta consigliando qualcosa a vitale di
nascosto non va bene per l'io devi
aiutare me lo tengo lo scampia
questo perché cosa mi ha detto berlino
cosa ti ha detto
molto utile prenderà sicuramente
secondo me vitale mette il cibo vicino
ruby quindi lo scambio parma l'anno
giusto però quindi vuol dire che sto
prendendo il cibo porte o forse cibo
cattivo
questo è l'ultimo round a quanti punti
stiamo io sono
è presto l'avvocato punto
mamma mamma
il nostro augurio bene non avevo posso
mangiare
è stata l'offerta a terra no volevo io
l'anguria
sembra purissima poi con questo caldo
almeno oil cobit anguria e ho
collezionato un sacco di pop hit in
questa challenger meno neanche un sacco
di punti io sono uno con questo 01
giudice
berline visto che mi avete aiutato io ti
avrei dato un pezzo di anguria l'italia
non dirà niente ma no non ci credo
vitale ha condiviso e al tronco
vitale ha condiviso un pezzo di anguria
con berlino è stata stoke arrivare tutto
tranne soprattutto quello sperticate un
papa che in faccia a vitale scrivete nei
commenti qual è stato il momento più
divertente se questo
un altro ci siamo un po vestiti come
l'anguria no io sono la buccia verde
magurean anche si paga mai
[Risate]
[Musica]
il giudice scappato via